Let's look at the answer to
our spatial locality quiz.
The question is, which memory
locations have spatial locality?
Remember that spacial locality says
that once we access a memory location,
we are likely to access
nearby memory locations soon.
For the variable j,
we keep reaccessing j, but we don't
know what's close to j so we can not
really say that j has spatial locality.
If we access j,
there is a lot of temporal locality but
not necessarily any spatial locality.
Same for sum.
We are accessing sum
very often by itself but
we're not really sure whether we're
accessing anything that is close to sum.
For elements of arr, we have seen
that there is no temporal locality.
Each element is accessed
only once in this loop.
However, there is a lot
of spatial locality.
Once we access arr of zero,
in the next iteration,
we'll be accessing arr of one,
and then, arr of two and so on.
So it is true that once we access
a memory location in this array,
we're likely to access
nearby location soon.
So this variable definitely
has spatial locality.
It turns out that the way
this program is compiled,
usually means that there will be some
spatial locality between j and sum.
J and sum are likely to be allocated
by the compiler on the stack
near each other, so
when we access sum and
then access j, that might be
an example of spatial locality.